se escriba la siguiente expresión
aplicando las propiedades asociativa y
conmutativa de la adición y después
muestra que ambas expresiones llegan a
los mismos resultados
tenemos 17.53 más o menos 7.5 lo primero
que vamos a hacer es resolver la
operación tal cual está escrita y
después jugaremos con las propiedades
conmutativa si asociativas
vamos a sumar 17.53
17.53
nos va a dar 20.5 y esto le vamos a
sumar el menos 7.5 por lo que ahora
vamos a sumar una cantidad negativa
exactamente lo mismo que restas esa
cantidad 20.5 menos 7.5 y esto va a ser
igual a 13
esta fue la primera manera de encontrar
la respuesta ahora usemos la propiedad
conmutativa que nos dice que podemos
conmutar o intercambiar estas cantidades
y vamos a cambiar el orden de estas
vamos a reescribir esto
cómo
- 7.5
y entre paréntesis podremos poner 17.53
por lo que sólo cambiamos el orden pero
vamos a usar también la propiedad
asociativa por lo que en lugar de tener
estos paréntesis que voy a borrar estos
paréntesis de aquí los voy a quitar
vamos a ponerlos
son más
vamos a escribirlo la propiedad
propiedad
asociativa asociativa
nos dice que si tenemos
este tipo de ecuación o operación además
ve entre paréntesis más se va a ser
igual a si yo tengo a más entre
paréntesis b más c
y ahora la propiedad conmutativa
escribimos propiedad
piedad
con
la diva nos dice que si tenemos
a más de esto va a ser igual a tener más
y el orden no va a importar así que
vamos esta expresión que acabamos de
poner aquí en donde aplicamos tanto la
propiedad asociativa como la conmutativa
tenemos que menos 7.5 17.5 esto va a ser
igual a 10 cerrados a esto le sumamos el
más 3 que tenemos acá más 3 nos dará
como resultado 113 que es el mismo
número que obtuvimos en esta ecuación
anterior
aquí lo que hice fue tomar la diferencia
entre estos dos números y ponerles el
signo del número mayor en este caso el
mayor es el positivo por lo que este
resultado fue positivo y así puede
continuar con la operación y podríamos
continuar cambiando el orden de los
números y de los paréntesis y siempre
terminaríamos obteniendo el 13